هذا صراع بين
القوات المسلحة السودانية والمجموعة شبه العسكرية القوية جدًا،
قوات الدعم السريع التي يقودها
أقوى رجلين عسكريين في السودان. لقد حدث
بعد الساعة الخامسة مساءً في السودان وقد شهدنا
يومًا كاملاً من إطلاق النار الكثيف و  مكافحة
الدخان المتصاعد من بعض المباني التي
تم الإبلاغ عن قتال حول
مقر الجيش والقصر الرئاسي
والتلفزيون الحكومي أيضًا، وهناك تبادل
للوم وإلقاء اللوم بين
قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش حول من هاجم أولاً ولكن
هذه التوترات كانت تتراكم في
الماضي  أسبوعين وخاصة
هذا الأسبوع، وكان هذا سيحدث دائمًا
في هذا الوضع المتوتر حقًا،
هذا الترتيب الصعب في
محاولة لإعادة السودان إلى
الحكم المدني منذ انقلاب أكتوبر 2021 الذي
ذكرته، السودان يحكمه ما
يسمى بـ  المجلس السيادي زعيم
مجلس السيادة الفريق البرهان
هو أيضا القائد الفعلي للمؤسسة
العسكرية والبلاد